let's talk about the establishment let's
talk about this story from
the hill so the hill is described by
newsguard as an 80 out of 100 in terms
of credibility
they don't regular they don't regularly
collect correct their errors and they
don't disclose their financing but for
the most part they're a
very very reputable outlet fauci
bombshell
not convinced covid19 developed
naturally outside wuhan lab
interesting i seem to recall a a
president what was his name he was
orange
he had the weird hair donald trump who
said they were investigating this theory
and then um it was it was it was the um
this one paper of of of
merit and repute that says democracy
dies in darkness that claimed over and
over again it was a conspiracy theory in
cnn
and reuters and a bunch of other outlets
alluded to
or insinuated or outright said lab leak
is a conspiracy theory
right-wing media sites blah blah blah
why
because donald trump said it it was a
story in the washington post i remember
reading
that actually said questions rise about
a potential lab leak
there was a story in the daily mail
which said something similar and then
donald trump had to open his mouth and
the media
they as we were talking about don lemon
they built themselves off of
i ca i can just imagine it you're
sitting in the editorial meeting
it's like so uh it's 9 a.m and you walk
in and there's president zucker
all right guys what's in the news today
well we got this interesting story about
a potential uh lab league that kova may
have come from a lab
really wow now run with it that's a huge
story what else we got
uh donald trump said the lab like whoa
whoa whoa stop he runs out catches the
guys
don't run that story don't run that
story come back come back to the meeting
then go back in
okay uh donald trump pushed unhinged
conspiracy theory roll it
so all of a sudden stories that were
either based in fact this is the
craziest thing donald trump
would read the news you know ian
crossland does backflip then he'd go out
and be like this guy ian you see him
this ian does a backflip it's amazing
and they'll be like ian does front flip
trump lies
and you're just like what would it what
is this that's what they built
themselves off of
so now we have fauci i think this is as
what is 10th or 12th flip-flop
fauchi has you could make a video this
is someone should do this if you're
listening someone do this
take all the video clips of fauci
advocating a position and then put it
next to
fauci advocating the opposite position
and have him debate himself so um
louder with crowder actually did that oh
he did it together we put it into a clip
they beat us to it i know
there you go yeah well what's what's so
amazing
is is that it you know it hasn't just
been you know
fouchy i mean kamala harris was talking
about how she wasn't sure whether she
would take the vaccine
that was developed under trump and then
they had the audacity to be talking
about
we've got these vaccine skeptic people
oh really
really you spent the last year telling
people it would be five ten years before
we got a vaccine
if it was before then then it probably
was gonna be trustworthy because trump
can't be trusted
now they want people to completely and
totally forget about that and say
you gotta go out and you gotta get your
vaccine well now they want people to be
drunk
right go to the bar and give him free
beer it's out in front of a 7-eleven
it's like
okay i do find it funny that that a lot
of the people who are
opposing the vaccine were trump
supporters or our trump supporters
and then a lot of people who are getting
it won't give trump credit for doing the
job
to be fair a lot of people always bring
up you can support them producing a
vaccine but still think
it should be a choice like the doctor
should decide yeah but that wasn't but
that's not what they were saying during
the
campaign they were saying that trump was
lying to people about getting a vaccine
we were never going to have a vaccine by
january of 2021. we had kamala harris
out there talking about how
who knows if it'd be safe i'm not sure
whether i would trust and wasn't it
wasn't it biden too like biden kamala
like cuomo
they had all been like i don't know you
gotta wait for the science
i think i think a bunch of democrats
came out and said it oh absolutely i
started tweeting that they were
anti-vaxxers
well but this is essentially their
entire all of their positions were
dictated by
as you pointed out what trump said if
trump had actually come out and said you
want to know what vaccines are going to
be bad
they would have been telling us we're
going to have a vaccine tomorrow it's
going to be the greatest thing since
sliced bread
like they're everything that they all of
their positions
were premised on whatever donald trump
was for it's by the way it's why the
democratic party has had this bizarre
flip-flop
on suddenly becoming the party of
foreign intervention all over the world
because trump was against foreign
interventionism so
so now bill crystal feels at home in the
new democratic party
i gotta give a shout out to the babylon
bee again because we have this
satirical satirical article article
ingenious move trump supports
impeachment
forcing democrats to oppose
again that really what it was again that
that seems like
insane but it also hits so close to home
i mean
so so this vouchy thing about the lab
leak is
in my opinion it shouldn't be news fauci
is a very dumb and dangerous person
he he was the one who for hold on let me
slow down
fauci lied about masks this is this is a
fact
that fauci has admitted to that early on
he told people not to wear masks
this is this is the i love this he then
came out later and said
well you know we wanted people to not
buy the mask so that
the the medical professionals could have
them why do medical professionals need
masks
why why do they why do the medical
professionals need the mat professionals
need those masks anybody
so they don't breathe pathogens into
open wounds while they're doing surgery
so so because of covet right like they
don't want to pass disease but why do
they need more than they already have
why was it so important
that we get all of these masks not to
the people but to the medical
professionals
so the insinuation is the medical
professionals needed more masks than
usual
right what was happening that was
alarming everybody
that made us think doctors needed more
masks
this is why there was a there was a
pandemic beginning yeah there was a
pandemic going on
now how do you prevent the pandemic you
get regular people to wear masks
so if fauci came out and said you should
all be wearing your masks
right away then the doctors would not
have needed so many
because people wouldn't be dying in
hospitals because they didn't have masks
fauci admitted he wanted the doctors to
have them
because he's a [ __ ] because he doesn't
understand cause and effect
and now all of these people line up as
though his word is gospel let me just
reiterate that
if from the beginning fauci said just
wear a mask
the doctors would not have needed as
many because there would be less
sick people in hospitals he lied
people died and it contributed to the
overwhelming of the system this guy
is a [ __ ] who thinks he's smart and all
he does
is he repeats what the news said but two
days later
i've made that point since since the
mask thing reversal happened i was like
is this guy just coming out and
repeating what he saw on cnn two days
ago
and now here we are again we have this
story about fauci saying
i you know i'm not convinced the virus
you know originated naturally
oh is it because the news broke in the
past few months
that lab leak was a real potential and
now fauci flip flops again
my favorite my favorite absolute
favorite fauci is on its show
and he gets asked should people wear
double masks to masks
and he goes it's just common sense that
if you want to layer and you have to it
would provide more protection
then he goes on another show there's no
data suggesting two masks
is is better and it is not being
recommended and then a few days like 10
days later
the cdc recommends two masks the dude is
so dumb
he is on every side of the debate and he
is responsible for many people in cities
being dead
because he said don't wear masks for a
stupid reason well and by the way
look it's not just around mass that
people ignored the science that fauci
and our overlords ignored the science i
mean from the very beginning we knew
that that the the survivability rate
from covet was incredibly high
the people who were at most the most at
risk were the elderly and people who had
multiple comorbidities
from the very beginning our effort
should have been to protect those people
what did cuomo do he put those people in
the worst situation possible said hey
sick let's sell them shove them back
into uh you know rest homes and we'll
get other people sick and more people
will die
we we had uh janice dinon ah she's so
good but you know about her her uh
her in-laws yeah she lost both of her
in-laws because uh i'm i'm just gonna
say i quote
cuomo murdered those people he was
advised this would kill people
he had the option to use the jevit
center or was it the mercy yep that
he didn't do it because he didn't want
to help trump of course absolutely
absolutely new york was new york was
struggling and trump
being the executive you know sent things
to new york
at the javits center at the you know
with the mercy that they never used
again because politics was more
important than people's lives doesn't
this
constitute you know there was this uh
princeton professor years ago said we're
in a cold civil war
we refer to it as the culture war but we
refer to it as war because people have
uh well there's cold war and there's hot
war and people have been killed
and there has been a lot of violence but
we're not at a point where it's like a
traditional hot war where there's like
armed factions or anything
but maybe it's because we're becoming
too blind to what conflict actually
looks like
maybe conflict looks like a governor
knowingly putting sick people in nursing
homes killing 15 000 people
maybe warfare looks like democrats
advocating for the secession of the west
coast this is john podesta reported by
the boston globe
if donald trump wins maybe this is the
media
lying maybe this is fouchy flip-flopping
maybe it is
your political leaders willing to let
you die
for political power and it's two
different factions
there's a bunch of smaller sub-factions
within the parent factions
unfortunately for those that oppose the
democrats the republicans are
mostly a bunch of jellyfish flopping
around doing nothing so instead
we sit here and watch as cuomo literally
knowingly puts sick people in nursing
homes resulting in fifteen thousand dead
and the dude gets a book deal and an
emmy an enemy he won an emmy
justice no no and by the way like look
this guy is still like
first off what he did with the nursing
home scandal is absolutely unbelievable
you'd think that any decent governor
would resign
how many women now have come out and
claiming gruesome and wolf yeah look at
that
there's no there's no there's no
accountability and democrats learned a
long time ago
they don't have to be accountable the
media is not going to
hold them accountable so if the media is
not going to hold them accountable
why should they why should they bother
ralph northam is still the governor
of virginia he's out there you know
terry mcallister they're touting his
endorsement and this is the guy who is
in the either in blackface or in the kkk
outfit
yeah which one i don't think it matters
i think either way the guys got to get
out of there but they don't care
yeah donald trump no he's the racist
right yes
not the guy not the governor who you
know his nickname in
uh undergrad was [ __ ] man that was his
nickname [ __ ] man
and then by the way you remember after
he admitted that it was him
then 24 hours later he came out and said
actually i thought about some more i
don't think it actually was me
but there was this other time that i did
blackface but that was just a
party and i'm like is this for real i
was like man this guy's done like 24
hours no no no no
it's tribalism yeah it is so deeply
tribal
that socialists have aligned themselves
with the one percent the wealthy elites
because they hate donald trump it is the
most insane
thing i mean think about it the the
occupy wall street people not all of
them because it kind of split
but many of those activists are are
voting for joe biden
i'm like yo you guys protested that dude
i was there i watched you protest that
dude
now you're voting for him yep well
because trump is worse what
didn't you want to like shake the system
up and challenge the establishment
donald trump is a bull in a china shop
no no trump is better he's a fascist
whatever man the the these it's been
absolutely
ridiculous for me to see these old
activists who protested the one percent
supporting
like the lincoln project david from
bill crystal like these these
republicans are getting support from
from socialists well and by the way
wonderful george w bush
is now adored by the left and the media
who this was chimpy mchitler remember
yeah like all these people
all these innocent children died in the
middle east because you know
bush wanted a war for oil apparently
that's all's forgiven now as long as you
as long as you hate trump all is
forgiven and now
and now you know we're gonna get from
these
they're they're you know
i said something about uh democrats
being dumb
on twitter there was a story from msnbc
that said the gop
you know pushes bill to make teaching
the history of slavery
you know illegal or to ban the teaching
of slavery and i'm like
clearly that's not real of course the
actual story is
critical race theory which is an
ideology which is not fact
and these people watch msnbc and they
believe it
and that's like you know the q anon
people believe
insane things like i'll tell you
absolutely every
i remember like every day after the
election i'd have people being like dude
i'm telling you it's tomorrow tomorrow
coming up where are you at bro i'm like
no no it's actually tomorrow i'm like
oh you're right it's tomorrow
permanently but they're not
institutional
they don't have massive power they're
not holding up infrastructure
msnbc is mainstream they're pumping
these
peop these people full of insane lies so
it's a good thing their ratings are
collapsing
but it still leaves us holding this bad
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you